thanks very much indeed for being with
us Lyn we're going to talk a little bit
more about the partnership and what
you're doing with the Lee Rigby
foundation in just a moment but better
many won't recognize you without the
Mullins and this book in many ways is an
unmasking it is telling truths that you
have wanted to tell for a long time but
felt unable to necessarily wanted to I
decided to this okay so I want to raise
the funds for the charity
so in the book yes you have written that
you are bisexual that's wrong if you
have been for many years you've known
this since you were four that you say
you were 17 when you should you realize
do you know and but you didn't feel able
to know you could come out they thought
that no those been the early days you
had to clip completely you know what we
now call in the closet door no you
couldn't be open about things like that
otherwise you could check your daily
date yourself with all wrestlers and
people in the sporting world you
couldn't suddenly start announcing that
type of thing now so there was a macho
image that you had to maintain I think
it goes on to this day as well there's a
lot of people out there this still
aren't out you know they're tough to
keep it buried because it's not you
can't do it even though it's not that
it's not that liberal even oh no so it's
not been an easy decision no for you to
do this why have you done it now one of
the main reasons is that I want to help
lint and and the Charter that we have
working together to provide for veterans
and people who had tragedies from
terrorism and things that so we're
building this to this organization where
we can help them they come to us for
retreat days and or even weeks and for
nice knowing and that's what we're doing
but we wanted to really make it big
well what's it about the Leroy P
foundation that made you want to get
involved about two years ago she came to
one of my retreat days which we do have
ascend Buddhism and we got talking to
each other and she told me what she
wanted
because I already knew about the
terrible thing that happened to me and
we bonded really to be honest and that
words are and we now with family really
well together and soul in and you were
given a house on the estate which is now
Lee Whitby house believe me we'd be
house and what do you use that for
basically we used up for when Lee died
we never really got any support not to
just get away as a family to grieve as a
family and as I said we moved on to
Kendall's estate and he offered us the
house on the estate I mean when I first
went there I just cried because that was
what I wanted you needed that yeah and
it was just peace you know just
everything just went you know and we use
that now we use it for buried military
families siblings veterans and their
families and now also we've opened it as
Peter was saying to UK terrorism victims
as well and you have plans to expand Lee
Rigby Lodge what will that well the next
the next phase now is the Veterans annex
which is attached to the main hall we
just have received planning permission
now well that is going to cost us nearly
half a million to a million pound to do
and that will be turned into 13 bed 6
and bedrooms self-contained you know
accommodation for the veterans as well
and for you and Peter having come from
life in the spotlight getting audiences
of what 14 million in your heyday and
you know live very much quieter more
tranquil nice yes I follow the Buddhist
way which is Zen that was taught me by
Ken Oshiro
abbey was my sensing Japanese sensing
and I just stood in that for years and I
first met him in 1956 and that's been
the basis of who I've become but you are
not going to go back on stage and are
you I read that you might be doing the
ceremonial I'm asking is that we've done
it
today we've done some on tonight yeah
we've restarted on Monday and we've got
the last one tonight okay and then we've
got a night off and then we're doing
Friday and Saturdays